.
- Une mer de drapeaux,oioioioios
et plus de 150 000 soi-disantpae
n'avait pas vraiment le droites.
Mais quand même, le stade
Loujniki, à Moscou, s'est
transformé en ce t t t t t t t .
(en russe)
Sur la scène, nul autre que
presque jamais en public,
accueilli en héros et en
commandant en chef de son armée.
(en russe)
Il allait aborder l'opération
en Ukraine quand son discours a
de la musique.
♪ ♪ ♪
la télévision d'État qui
diffusait le tout. Mais,
la foule sur place, elle, a pu
l'entendre promettre la victoire
(en russe)
Car, "c'est pour libérer Donesk
et Lougansk de génocetetet de la
et de la souffrance", dit-il.
♪ ♪ ♪
Une doctrine à laquelle
À Rjev, comme dans d'autres
villes, c'était i i i jour
de fête pour honorer
les troupes.
(en russe)
"Gloire à l'armée, gloire à la
Russie."
Dans cette ville de héros
de la Grande guerre, c'est
un devoir qui se transmet d'une
Mais, cette fois, avec
un nouveau symbole : ce "Z",
public.
"C'est un beau sy " " " " " " a
Pobedu", la victoire... la
victoire contre le fascisme."faà
la fin du mois de février sur
les chars de l'armée russe avant
qu'ils entrent en Ukraine. Mais,
et la foule s'en donne à coeur
joie. Même sur la scène
de l'opéra de Donesk,
jeu. Une propagande militair
qui s'étend aux écoles et
aux garderies.
"Bien sûr,tetetetete mère.
Nous sommes tendus avec tout
ce qui se passe, mais
pour protéger nos enfants."
Ce qui est pour l'Ukraine
l'emblème de l'horreur et
du cen Russie, le symbole
d'un patriotisme absolu
et sans scrupule.
Radio-Canada, Rigua